ladies and gentlemen as you all know the
revolutionary wave of demonstrations and
protests known as the Arab Spring
originated from Tunisia in December 2010
and then spread throughout the countries
of the Arab League and its surroundings
while the most radical transition from
the epic Arab Spring into civil wars
take place in Syria and Iraq as we have
seen there's major concern over the
protection of cultural heritage in
countries of the North African Maghreb
as well in Tunisia democracy has been
consolidated after the overthrow of
President Ben Ali in 2011 and
parliamentary elections and
presidentials have successfully been
held last autumn Libya has been governed
by two rival governments since August
2014 1 in Tobruk and an Islamist rival
government in Tripoli control of the
country is severely limited by the
current civil war between both
governments as well as the activity of
different jihadist groups and different
tribes that create a generally confusing
situation since 2011 there has been a
steady stream of reports detailing the
threats to Libya's cultural resources
from ideological destruction to
unchecked development in 2013 for
example constructing machines destroyed
parts of a necropolis of the ancient
Greek city of cerini one of the five
UNESCO World Heritage Sites in Libya
another world heritage site nada más
suffered rocket attacks in 2012 since
2011 to the present day Salafi Islamists
destroyed Sufi shrines and graves in the
whole country including the shut up
mosque in Tripoli it seems that there's
still no damage in museums but the
Department of Antiquities is taking
precautions such as hiding portable
objects and securing securing museums
perhaps the greatest threat to Libya's
diverse heritage is currently the
looting of archaeological sites and
trafficking of archaeological materials
to markets of ancient art
the few international initiatives for
the protection of cultural heritage
launched after 2011 in Libya itself have
now essentially stopped the escalation
of hostilities in the past nine month
has led many foreign embassies to close
and international organizations to leave
the country Tunisia's posted a
revolutionary period equally saw the
destruction of many sufi muslim
monuments in two thousand eleven and
twelve including the famous murder boot
of sidi bou site near tunis looting and
illicit excavation have been already
been a huge problem in Tunisia and
either Ben Ali period and the problem
still exists as the country's numerous
sites almost uncontrollable by security
forces and the natural heritage
institute an oppressive exposition in
the museum of carthage the tunisian
heritage institute shaped pieces that
have been illicitly excavated and
rescued from houses mainly of the ben
ali family after the Revolution well
aware that this is only the tip of the
iceberg due to the influx of weapons and
trained fighters mostly from Libya
Tunisia suffers from insecurity
particularly in the border regions to
Algeria and Libya insecurity that have
stopped most activities of foreign
archaeological missions in the Tunisian
hinterland last year the terrorist
attack and about door Museum of Tunis on
March 18th this year showed the
vulnerability of the country's tourism
industry which is also based on the
richness of Tunisia's cultural heritage
but it underlined also the particular
role of history archaeology and cultural
heritage in the discourse about identity
and social cohesion Tunisia and Libya
thus prevent two different sides of the
same coin while the situation in Libya
is so serious that helping inside the
country became almost impossible for
foreign missions Tunisia shows generally
similar problems but still a
considerably higher level of security
and stability that allows direct help
inside the country this leads us to the
question what we can do to support the
protection of cultural heritage in Libya
and Tunisia a key question in both
countries is as ever where the increase
of awareness and support of the public
if the local communities are not
convinced of the need of protecting the
cultural heritage in their own
neighborhood most of our efforts from
abroad will not be a fruit however
involvement of local communities is a
difficult task in both countries Libya s
Tunisia with the colonial period and
appropriation of the Roman remains in
particular by Europeans caused the
severe split between the population and
their archaeological heritage in Tunisia
they share in Tunisian visitors in
museums inside is about two percent of
the total which shows the urgent need of
reconciling locals with their heritage
in fact local opposition against
destruction of cultural heritage can be
extremely successful this is shown by
the fact that Tunisia succeeded in
slowing down the systematic destruction
of Sufi sides a success largely based on
the strong commitment of the local
communities protecting their own local
religious heritage an important example
of involvement of local communities is a
program for students in the Libyan town
chaahat ancient cerini that should have
been presented here by Ahmed Hussein was
unfortunately not able to come this
project pursues the objective of
involving the local community in the
tasks and duties of protecting and
preserving Libya's heritage professor
Hussein states that the fact that the
Libyan authorities the previously not
attempt to involve the local community
has led not only to ignorance among
community about our college and heritage
but also to a gap and understanding the
value of heritage in the first step of
this project lectures were given to
students of different secondaries
and shehad the second stab included
visits to the archaeological site with
special material given to the students
with basic information and explanation
about the sides and monuments I hunt
Hussein underlines the positive results
of this initiative that confirm the
reinforcement of the relationship
between heritage and people emphasizing
that the most important point in
protecting heritage is knowledge a
similar project has been organized by
the tunisian national heritage Institute
and the german archaeological institute
a team to ancient cemeteries the
Tunisian Northwest near the Algerian
frontier in this project we are training
local school teachers in history and
archaeology to enable them to visit the
side and the museum's with their classes
another museum based project is the
permanent exhibition of the hoard of
gold coins from seem to which is still
the largest gold treasure of late
antiquity in the Bardo Museum in Tunis a
joint project of the institut national
de patrimoine the Dai and the Museum of
carls who injure me this project was
tragically slowed down some weeks ago
with the destruction of the showcases
during the attacks and the necessity of
a new security concept probably but we
will now of course support our Tunisian
partners even stronger and open this
exposition as soon as possible the
educational project in team two is part
of a pro Rhoda program aiming to
strengthen the social and economic
dimension of local heritage in order to
ensure their assisted sustainability it
is part of a special program of the
German Federal Foreign Office to support
the process of democratic transformation
in North Africa and consists of a
schooling program for local craftsmen
reinforced public relations training
programs for employees of the tunisian
national heritage Institute summer
schools for students and in cooperation
with the local civil society public
lectures and guided tours these on-site
activities are accompanied by a major
program of research fellowships that
enable Tunisian
and now also Libyan scholars to work in
the libraries of the German illogical
Institute in Rome or Berlin as to the
research strategy in times of insecurity
we do not plan long-term excavations but
concentrate on assisting our partners to
securing the sites producing inventories
and cartographic documentation generally
these activities are focused on specific
training and operational means to ensure
effective prevention of illegal
excavation looting and illicit export of
cultural property as well as under
scholarly background for discussing the
archaeological evidence in a broader
social context a program managed by an
alien from Durham University analyzed
bachmann from the Rome Department of the
German archaeological Institute focuses
on the training of Libyan archaeologists
in various field worth techniques with
the aim of supporting Libya's Libya to
develop a strategy for the monitoring
and preservation of cultural heritage on
Libyan territory as it is currently
impossible to organize the trainings in
Libya the last two courses have been
successfully held in Tunisia in
cooperation with the University of sphax
the training concentrates on mapping
techniques such as remote sensing field
survey and GIS databases if we want to
fulfill the double task of protecting
exposed and vulnerable archaeological
remains for the for future generations
while facilitating research and
sustainable development of
archaeological site authorities need a
systematic site management approach that
addresses sides or cultural health
landscapes as a whole measures taken to
preserve and maintain cultural heritage
must build on its investigation and
documentation thinking of effective
strategies for protecting cultural
heritage in countries of crisis
digitalization and archiving photography
and map collections as well as the
creation of digital monumental registers
take an important part of help we can
actually deliver net
of different archaeological databases
confess facilitate research and
management of cultural heritage the
German archaeological Institute is
currently creating such a tool which
will combine different databases of
basic archaeological data objects sides
straight graphical data library
collections and digital publications
with secondly standardizing systems for
ecological terminology place names as
well as chronological concepts and terms
and thirdly analytical tools for texts
and data mining as well as pattern
recognition particularly the later camp
as we hope be useful tool for police and
customs officials confronted with
unknown archaeological objects and thus
a means against illicit trade of objects
the markets for illegally exported
archaeological artifacts are in our own
countries in Europe the United States
and the Gulf region effective measures
against illegal part of the art market
are crucial let only in the country's
discussed today the most effective help
however is support for the development
of stable political and economical
structures and security thank you very
much
you